hey guys I'm Brad Leonie from bone
Appetit Chris Morocco from bone Appetit
then we're gonna be answering some
questions off off the old Twitter and
you know let's have some fun get going
this is Thanksgiving support first
question first question this is from a
truss F 78 I'm cooking turkey for the
first time in years should I dry brine
or wet Brian I have a bottle of sweet
water spiced turkey brine in the
cupboard just in case you take a three
order spice it's right over your
shoulder over the shoulder do yourself a
real nice dry brine brining a turkey
specifically dry brining does a couple
different things so it's introducing
salt into the turkey and it's also
ultimately gonna help you dry out the
skin so you're gonna get deeper browning
you're gonna get more flavor and you're
gonna get crispier skin if you want it
to be delicious not just on the outside
you know so many turkeys I've had at
Thanksgiving where you slice it and it's
salty and tasty on the outside but
nothing no seasoning on the inside and
when you brine for at least a day I mean
you can do it for 12 hours if you need
to you're gonna penetrate all the way
through it just really is kind of a
game-changer yeah next question fresh
blunts add fresh blood best potato for
mashed potatoes I kind of can't stand a
starchy potato as a mashed potato
anything in the Yukon family is what I
call the new Conny family for sure all
right coming in from at hope dealer 101
how do you prepare brussel sprouts
my favorite way to do Brussels sprouts
is if you know like I love them deep
fried but that's usually impractical for
most the next best thing
high temperature roast just lightly
coated with oil halves have got a nip
yeah so I like the nip you know right
you nip fall off the little shaggy I dip
and then we uh and then I like the half
right down the bone there so we'll put
them in a bowl we'll toss them a little
olive oil and salt
well toss it to us yeah there we go so
we want to place these face down so that
we get you know if you put it on like
that you're only gonna get a little bit
of surface area it's gonna pick up a
little bit of browning on that round and
then now we got this nice little flat
face you put that down there the whole
thing picks up color and then the other
Oh what's have you got there 454 15 high
heat very well check out them in 20
minutes give em a little toss if we need
to I'd imagine they're gonna take 30
here's what I'm feeling for the Brussels
sprouts yeah talk to me talk talk to me
I want little saucepan melt some butter
maple hot sauce or salt why the saucepan
just so that the butter can melt and
then we can like do another toss toss so
the brussel sprouts like we can you know
whatever come out ripping hot you got
our butter you got the other things you
mentioned right back in the big little
big bowl yeah that's it right in there
no salt I know - man no saucepan all
right I'll get the bowl that's what
we're looking for as you get them dump
them right in here huh all right
nice nice all right great job boom in
goes the butter
all right here we're gonna put a little
pinch of black pepper - okay yeah yeah
like you're playing the garlic that's a
touch hot top and then what you thinking
a little maple yeah and hot sauce almost
like you were doing like chicken wings
that's good oh hello nice I like that
Chris oh it smells good doesn't it
I think the garlic was inspired Oh looks
like a little punch
yeah Brussels sprouts nailed it boom
next question Katrina bonnet at cat lb
ff5 do you use butter or shortening in
your pie crust butter
personally I prefer shortening I like
the texture better and I and I think it
holds up better when you're cutting the
pie flavor you know the flavor is not
better and that's what I wanted to say
like I would highly encourage you to
kind of try all-butter crust again I
just think the flavor development you
get even if the crust can be a little
bit harder to work with
you know that's worth it your butter I
mean yeah you you can't beat that
no you can't I love answering questions
this is from Emily Becker do you put
celery in your stuffing yeah hard yes
Harve yeah hard yes there's something
about celery and its ability to cut
through it just has so much flavor it
really cuts through
and brings like a really Pleasant
vegetal note which you kind of need to
counterbalance all the fat all the
starch you know and in the form of
whether it's corn bread or regular bread
Nick and Nicolas underscore Scott 1t 93
why are people so convinced I'm going to
start a huge fire deep frying a turkey
as if I'm at accident oh oh maybe you
are maybe your friends know you and
they're just looking out for you because
it can be very good maybe they know
something we don't
the most important thing is because yeah
you're dealing with a decent amount of
volume a very hot oil get on the
internet or go down in your store or
something and get like a deep frying
Turkey kit you want something to get
died cylinder not real wide high
cylinder you want don't you know don't
go using your twine that's been in the
garage for 30 years to lower into
350-degree oil so it breaks and
splatters all over the place on your
face okay
you want to get the nice stuff with a
little thing the nice if you're gonna do
it do it right great next question Nick
this is from Lana Petri how many sticks
of butter do people go through on
Thanksgiving while cooking I'm on stick
10 and not slowing down yeah you wanna
you wanna you want to stock up get
yourself a pallet alright yeah
last thing you wanna do is run out of
butter I like to use dried chickpeas
Kabuli chana as high weights when I'm
blind baking pie crust what do you use I
acquired a bin full of a quarter inch
stainless steel ball bearings machine
grade they weigh about 20 pounds they're
fantastic yeah they hold heat really
nicely and they happen because they're
you know it's steel it's pretty heavy
little expensive they're an inventive
but if you you know but they last
forever yeah this is from Vanessa north
yeah heart heart heart says I don't have
brandy for my cranberry sauce and I'm
honestly thinking of just using tequila
instead because I doubt anybody will
actually notice am i the literal worse
no you're fine why not just like drink
it instead
take the shot get back to work yeah this
is a fiver I would have said but but
maybe favor okay
Thanksgiving question how do you keep
your turkey moist while roasting it has
everything to do with like what not to
do
right do not over cook your turkey do
brine your turkey I feel like there's
this whole thing like oh if I baste it
if I spoon this liquid over it then like
that's somehow getting liquid inside the
turkey yeah don't base and if you're
thinking that it's going to put any type
of moisture back into the turkey I mean
I feel very comfortable saying that down
you need to rest your turkey a whole
visit sighs turkey at least an hour it's
gonna be ready yeah at typical hours
even let it hang out next question can
someone please explain to me how you
spatchcock a turkey yeah so we're
basically just saying why are you
fighting the backbone now yeah
same way you spatchcock a chicken you're
gonna cut the backbone out and you're
gonna open up and flatten I'm screwed
crush it out got one caught one
yeah I'm so bored big board big surface
area wet towel or something so that
doesn't slide around then boom we're
lying now we flipped it right over you
can almost see yeah there's like one
yeah yep we're just gonna follow those
all right I'm gonna give it a go sorry I
just sort of a CMD we're gonna do this I
don't mind
I'm here for support well that goes
through actually relatively easy nice
second side a little trickier oh joy and
on that careful which a because I'm in
caught a bunch of you do not want to cut
yourself with a serrated turkey stays
put you know the knife is always cutting
down towards the board not like
laterally scalpel not towards Chris boom
there you go backbone sometimes a little
scoring just helps it kind of break how
it helps that keel bone to crack Oh a
little relief strip not so much there
but like yeah like right there just to
kind of flatten it up open it up because
you have to pop the breastbone
to get it to be able to flatten properly
do not bad
flip flip it over so now the whole thing
you've taken like a very
three-dimensional package and turned it
into a much more about two-dimensional
package nobody who is that no big deal
next question who has that energy to go
Black Friday shopping you should be in
bed barely alive noticing your hangover
with a gallon of truck trying tryptophan
tryptophan still coursing through your
veins like everyone else the day after
Thanksgiving I don't know if I buy the
whole turkey tryptophan it makes your
tire is it's like overblown it's in all
kinds of stuff it's in you know certain
dairy products like cheeses and other
meats pork absolutely like even more
than turkey you know and in fairness
yeah okay so like tryptophan like you
feel the effects more when you're
consuming things with tryptophan that
are high liking carbs did the whole
tryptophan thing I think is like
completely overblown yeah and like we
should just like let it go
be Marshall 898 I wonder if she was born
in 98 that's when I graduated from high
school well Chris that's just horrifying
anyone ever smoked a turkey so many
recipes give such an array of cooking
times yes and yes it's a hundred percent
dependent on the temperature the smoke
that's affecting aroma but that's not
actually what's cooking your meat what's
cooking your meat is the temperature
inside the smoking environment the smoke
is a smoker right it's a smoky oven so
you know if you're doing at you know 250
degrees it's gonna take a lot longer
than if you're doing it at 300 exactly
and I mean smoked turkeys are fantastic
so I mean if you've had the ability to
do it I would certainly try it
definitely brought my Brian driver I
Brian and smoke game change fantastic
next day cold cuts forget about open up
a deli alright so this is from Sarah I
need to make a non pumpkin dessert for
Thanksgiving next week and I'd prefer
not to make a pie crust
I'm agonizing here any suggestions make
a chocolate cake that's what honestly
personally nine days out of ten you give
me a good chocolate cake like the one
you know we made you know the easiest
ever chocolate birthday cake I'm sorry
like that is the perfect dessert there
is no better brain cake
okay how are vegan mashed potatoes not
good like is it possible to recreate the
creamy deliciousness without butter and
evaporated evaporated milk get a little
creative and you know make that they
sell all kinds of all
turn ative like dairy products like
vegan crush sour cream or I don't know
and try folding at a we're a little salt
and some olive oil or something what's
wrong what's wrong with a crispy potato
you know what I mean like you can do
like the the crispy the gold burnished
potato nuggets like based on English
style Rosie those delicious make that
jinx of those just make those they're
better than Master divot yeah has anyone
tried maple syrup as a glaze for carrots
yes any good yeah normally I do honey
mustard but have the vegan but have the
vive vegan the vegan the vegan coming
this year carrot maple good things so
yeah absolutely
Jennifer Leslie bedecker hashtag
Thanksgiving grocery shopping dilemma
when a recipe calls for butter how do
you set up how do you decide between
salted and unsalted um I can tell you
unequivocally if it's a bone Appetit
recipe which you should unequivocally be
using it will specify salted versus
unsalted I think it's a matter of
control right we are unsalted just
because we want people to be like very
deliberate about how much salt they're
adding different brands of butter may
have different amounts of salt it
becomes very hard to control I think
just get a good unsalted butter
mm-hm you can just salt to taste yeah
thanks for calling Jen this is from
eyelid Johnson nice name I love ya real
nice
how many sides do you typically have on
your Thanksgiving table and eat
must-haves
each year yeah do you have a like go to
go to number but man I'm a little upset
if stuffing or dressing I got I need
that better be there
yeah cranberry sauce for sure love
cranberry so is it gelled and I am NOT
eating cranberry sauce laurels arms I
need gravy
some kind of potato I love a little
salad yeah there should be salad or some
vegetable but like I don't have
something I'm like oh man it's like
grandma's green bean casserole in on
this right it's not Thanksgiving like I
don't care how do i thicken gravy
the most common would probably be a roux
you know just what when you have a fat
Ashley butter usually butter not always
and you bring that
get that warm and then you just whisk in
flower and that it becomes a thickening
agent very classic and what a Cajun in
French cuisine yeah sure you can make a
cornstarch slurry that's a great way to
just bump up the thickening it's
definitely the easiest what do we want
to do I know we got a babies that we can
thicken up to her over in gravy land cuz
we got some loose gravy you got one
right here look at this don't even have
to loose you don't want to pour that
litter that's loose let's make a roux
I want the butter to melt and I don't
want to brown it you know little brother
wham-o yep at least a tablespoon of
flour per quart per quart it's starting
to foam well thanks forming so the
reason you don't want to add flour loose
flour directly into your gravy is that
it's going to clump up and you're gonna
have lumps it's also because it's in a
raw state so you really want to kind of
toast the the flour a little bit just
get a little bit of that nutty or kind
of characteristic a little bit of that
raw flour barriness to kind of dissipate
alright we're going so like I do just
like one shot boom right in and like
kind of whisking don't fall into the
trap of not boiling your gravy and then
thinking that it needs more thickener
that's a very good point it is yeah and
then you bring it up and then all of a
sudden you got glue look at that yeah it
wants to coat the spoon now that looks
good
those are good a few more minutes of
simmering and that's good to go
see you hand it up so the roux works
pretty easy it's pretty straightforward
there's another method that we're
talking about having that cornstarch
slurry same deal you don't want to just
sprinkle it into your liquid because
it's gonna disperse unevenly so for two
teaspoons of cornstarch I'm probably
gonna add a tablespoon or so of water do
we have to use water could we just use
this it's why I introduced more liquid
is we're trying to thicken I'm just
thinking that now I wanna know I this is
I mean maybe we can just crack the code
right make sense of my little peanut
brain some yeah for sure man alright
tell me I don't see why it wouldn't work
right so that is our slurry right yes
sir it's it's the consistency of heavy
cream all right yeah you don't want it
to be a pace do you want it to be fluid
the reason being that you want this to
disperse evenly and very quickly it
again heat
debated heat-activated so I would say
you love this it's okay for this to be
warm when you add it you do not want
this to be ripping hot when you add it
because it'll start to set and activate
the cornstarch and you'll get in ribbons
yeah yeah you'll have like some weird
but you want zelve it throughout yeah
exactly so whisk oh yeah boom so we're
gonna crank the heat up on that yeah
disseminates & Tricks very old heat
activation yeah very old very old - all
right Jason
Kobus is gravy just Turkey yogurt know
what what what is that I god Jason Jason
hold on just it's he's not worth your
time damn it Jason we're having a good
run Jason so this is from mess BQ
attempting to ferment some cranberry
raspberry relish maybe I should add a
red Savina red Savina with a little
purple jelly emoji yeah a little heat um
I would definitely mess around that
before you I wouldn't make one and dump
it on Louisville I wouldn't like make
like five gallons of it I think you
might be the support important question
where do people stand on the cornbread
stuffing I'm a huge fan of cornbread but
I'm out on it as a stuffing I don't know
what that mean - tag my gooses I don't
know that means so love cornbread
stuffing
cornbread because corn flavor just has
so much intensity of aroma and and
flavor you can bring other elements into
it like strong elements like he take it
that's more than you salt more than you
think like a sponge it's a flavor sponge
why is it half Apple half pumpkin pie a
thing yeah I think it would be a
nightmare to make yeah I don't think you
have you ever made a pie before just
make no just like pumpkin tends to be a
blind baked crust with a custard filling
then set into it open and face whatever
Apple you know traditionally intends to
lean a little bit more on the double
crust two different pies for small
apples and pumpkins here okay
exactly sorry mark it's there's a good
reason for this okay we thought about it
why do people hand out raw frozen
turkeys on Thanksgiving
that's 32-hour ungrateful my god
oh I got a defrost it too bad but insane
oh right you don't have to take it just
take it
well fire fresh look it's just from like
a supply chain standpoint a fresh turkey
has like a much shorter shelf life a
frozen turkey is good you know it's
abundantly but yeah you got a you got a
defrost it you got to just let that
process grateful gee yeah that matched a
little disappointed whoa Chupacabra is
asking when is the best day to throw
away Thanksgiving leftovers asking for
me Oh week why don't you eat them before
I get there before they get there you
know how to make nice whipped cream
that's not a question is it
it's a little rough how does one make a
nice whipped cream we're gonna we're
gonna show you how gold cream big bolt
big bowl big whisk you can have seven
gallons of powdered sugar and I'm you
take the maple so I'll do the maple I'm
fine as I love and I'm very comfortable
with that for a little bit of sugar a
little pinch of salt always look you can
already see it's starting to get a
little frothy Oh little bit of salt is
how has any story show bring out the
flavor a little bit more maple oh so
basically the whipped cream is done when
you can hold the bowl inverted and
nothing's gonna flow out Bravo this is a
little bit you know soft peak it's gonna
mostly hold its shape but still has a
touch of fluid fluidity to it
you can go to medium Peaks do not go try
to go to stiff peaks on the whipped
cream there's kind of no way to even
really properly do that unless you're
stabilizing it or something you can do
this a little bit of ahead yeah just
whip it until it's very soft peaks and
then come back you know keep it in the
fridge nice and cold come back REE whip
it you know ten more seconds and you're
they
so you can hold it like that for you
know our whatever you need
alright guys well thanks for writing in
your questions me and old Morocco here
had a blast answer them yeah hopefully
uh hopefully they invite us again next
year we get again yeah finally if we
didn't screw it up too bad you kidding
me we nailed it alright I think we
nailed it well thanks guys leave some
comments let us know some more things
you'd like to us to answer and maybe
we'll get to them until next time thank
you